he claims he's scientific but this video
is horrific he's the washed-up 90s nerd
who just dropped a propaganda turd
terrible emily bill nye the science
whatever created a tick-tock video
promoting biden's infrastructure plan
build back better
other than schools it's the best place
to indoctrinate tweens and boy does it
suck
please consider the following if you're
like me you want the u.s to be a bit
better and for that we have two bills
and i'm not either one of them i mean
i'm a bill i'm not an infrastructure
bill you've heard about that the house
of representatives passed it recently
that's for our roads our power lines our
water pipes to upgrade them and
improvement so that we can have a better
infrastructure
interesting it gets better
i'm lying
so that we can working together build
back better you're using my lines here i
really am a believer in this you know
i'm old enough
to remember when the us was the leader
in innovation that's who we're driving
at bill driving yes we love driving yes
we do and uh electric cars are the
future they're clean they're efficient
they're quiet we're gonna build
500 000 charging stations and we want to
electrify our ground transportation so
we don't have this carbon in the
atmosphere
i don't i'm not even sure they were
together
the chemistry were any more electric
poor people couldn't afford it this year
more cringe-worthy than the time i
walked in on kilmeade's pedicure
he has eight toes per foot
we pretty much showed you the whole clip
so finish it
i say all the time article 1 section 8
clause 8 the progress of science and
useful arts it's in the constitution
come on everybody what's not to love
we're just trying to change the world
here people we're going to change the
world infrastructure is cool is that
what we do nowadays
so naturally people on twitter are
ripping the video apart missing the
bigger point that at least they weren't
naked
i kid but my point is things can always
be worse originally they had seth rogen
do the video and i think we have tape
you done
okay
wow
[Applause]
so mikey um
is it accurate to call this propaganda
or is it i mean
he's trying to get people to be okay
with spending trillions on stuff yeah
he's working for the government it's not
i mean you could i suppose it's the
worst piece of propaganda i've ever seen
and and you work for the cia
and i worked at the cia so i got us all
hooked on crack in the 90s
there was that there was mk ultra there
was uh
no uh we didn't do the crack thing by
the way i know i know which camera do i
look at we didn't do the crack thing uh
so yeah no it is it's it's so bad that i
guess what happened was they probably
didn't mean for it to be bad then they
looked at the first cut and they
realized the only way we can do this is
by making it really cringe-worthy
because then it'll get talked about as
we're doing right now i think it was
deliberate
after their first rough cut when they
realized they got nothing here let's
just make it as awful as possible really
you think they're actually really really
cool yeah they purposely decided i don't
think so
i don't think so i think their marketing
team or their messaging team made the
only decision they could at a certain
point and so we got to just we got to
make this thing so crappy that people
will talk about i guess i get it a lot
of people like i'm a lot taller than
people think but the way i sit i try to
appear shorter right um just to make
people feel more at ease around me ha ha
look at the short guy they don't know
they don't know emily uh you were a 90s
kid weren't you i was an 80s kid oh
really so you're in your 60s now i was
born in the 70s really well good for you
and you still get around time i do you
still get around the life alert okay
do you like bill nye no you care no
you guys that was agonizing yeah that
was watching two geriatric has-beens who
both peaked decades ago that was like
cocoon five
grumpiest ultimate to be fair one of the
house benz is a president
tax dollars paid for that absolutely not
i found that despicable honestly the
only thing worse more cringe-worthy than
that agonizing theater was maybe our
vice president paying fake kids and a
canadian company to talk about space
that fake the whole thing too like i
can't decide which is worse those two
crypt keepers or her laugh on that fake
space video either way our tax dollars
paid for it i'm not here for it
peter are we bit are we being too harsh
i really think you are yeah
i really do but i don't think you're
being too harsh about the vice president
hiring child actors that was just a
grotesque but yeah i think you're being
too hard on this he actually i think i
know bill and i saw he he believes it
he believes it he's sincere
uh i don't i honestly don't understand
what the problem is no that's okay
wasting our time all right again we're
gonna have to edit that out peter
we're gonna have to edit that whole
segment okay just say this just
just repeat after me peter this is the
most atrocious piece of video i've ever
seen
okay you might not like the way that was
presented or the style you may think
it's cringe-worthy but it's not
unethical no i don't i don't think it's
unethical it's annoying i don't want my
tax dollars to pay for it
he's trying to put on a message that he
believes in and he's trying to do it in
a way that he that he believes is hip i
don't see what the problem with that is
let's go to um our expert and
um thank you
you do realize that yeah peter will be
cut out of the entire show
joe looked like a hologram
was i was more worried about him making
it through the the video
yeah i mean your thoughts my thought i
mean like
like no it was not cool
no it's like infrastructure is not cool
it just
is
the ridiculous thing to call cool i know
it's not cool and i work at on cable
news so like i'm not really cool
i dare you oh you think i'm cool that's
the he just sort of accidentally called
me cool that's the nicest thing you've
ever said
thank you um
i don't she deserves no applause
i i i don't think i don't think tax
dollars should be spent on anything
so i i also agree with you but also i
don't think they should be spent on like
anything
because they shouldn't exist but yeah it
was annoying it was super annoying but
you know if they had fun then you know
i'm i'm glad for them yeah you know um i
i you know let's be honest it was a slow
news day and you know you always try to
look for some funny video that's all it
was yeah no i don't think there was but
it's the worst thing i've ever seen i
think it's an impeachable offense peter
i think it's a peach boy vigilante
justin
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else